[Music]
was it a mistake to send our children
back to school
the number of infections is rising
rapidly among kids
and what do we do we prioritize teachers
to get vaccinated
sooner children are still at the back of
the queue
but kids can also get sick with covid19
and seriously too
what's more they can also develop what's
known as long coved
meaning they can suffer long-term damage
regardless of whether they have shown
symptoms after their initial infection
or not
at their crucial age for development it
could impact
the rest of their lives so are we doing
enough to protect our children
because there could be much more at
stake for the young in this pandemic
than we have so far wanted to admit
[Music]
welcome to our kobe 19 special i'm
monica jones good to have you with us
now we all know the feeling of being out
of breath after
going up the stairs for example that's
quite normal usually
but not in times of covet 19 and not
when kids are affected what does long
kovitch do to them
a condition that keeps covid19 patients
down for weeks even months beyond the
initial illness
an italian study on long-coveted
children surveyed
kids and teenagers five months after
being diagnosed with covid19
only 42 of them had fully recovered
36 showed one or two long covet symptoms
while 22 showed at least three symptoms
symptoms such
sleep disorders breathing difficulties
muscle and joint pain
plus exhaustion headaches and an overall
lack of concentration basically all
symptoms that ultimately stop kids from
being kids
full of energy and life
francis simpson is a lecturer in
psychology and counselling at coventry
university in scarborough
she also co-founded the campaign long
covet kids and she joins us now
good to have you with us um you and your
children
had coveted 19 last year when did you
know it was covet 19 given that testing
was still scarce
uh that's a really good question we um
became ill at the beginning of march
uh and at the time obviously the the
narrative was very
simple about you know um that there was
either
um you know a flu-like thing with a
cough and a temperature or
um you know if you were clinically
vulnerable or old that you would end up
you know in hospital possibly uh being
ventilated
um so when we got this you know i got
ill with a range of
symptoms that were a bit like a cold and
my
daughter had slightly different symptoms
my son had different symptoms again
initially you know i didn't really put
two and two together
um and it was only when i lost my sense
of smell and taste and at the time that
wasn't a known
symptom um but when i googled it it said
that in iran
at the time of the pandemic it was the
most um
the most searched for term in google and
i thought okay
putting two and two together i think
this must be coronavirus
um and i went for when i tried to speak
to the doctors about it they said oh no
that's not a symptom
so it was very it was very difficult at
the time to get people to actually
believe that that was
that that was what it was and of course
everybody
was googling back then because we knew
so little about it
so when did you realize that uh you
might actually suffer from
what we now know as long covid
so i've for me um i just didn't didn't
seem to make a recovery
um so there wasn't particularly a time i
think after about six weeks i had a
brief recovery
uh and then i was ill again but it felt
very um
you know i describe it's a bit like a
roller coaster of
different symptoms coming and going
and uh and sort of occasional
day better days and then worst days it
just felt like i wasn't really getting
better
and and it felt such a um an unknown
kind of uh illness because of all these
different symptoms
my daughter was really poorly for six
weeks
um and then she
didn't really get better she kind of
continued with fatigue
um you know nausea and other symptoms uh
yeah we just saw
we just saw we just saw pictures of your
daughter and your son just now as you
were telling us
would you say that what we now know is
long covid
uh that it manifests itself differently
with children than with
adults well we've done some research
uh with long covered kids um and we've
sort of established that actually a lot
of the symptoms are very similar
but children do tend to have
an increased amount of gastric issues
quite often
we have found children um ending up with
you know appendicitis you know or
peritonitis
we see quite a lot of the hymns like
symptoms you know
the pediatric inflammatory multi-system
disorder we see sort of similar symptoms
to that
but we're also seeing um
neuropsychiatric symptoms you know so
things like
uh ticks tourette's uh seizures
uh so there's a real gamut of different
symptoms in
children kind of manifest slightly
differently um so there's a lot of the
same
symptoms as adults and there are certain
features that seem to be particularly
key in the pediatric cohort there is of
course still very little known
about long coverage even with adults uh
and that is probably
why uh you co-founded a campaign
known as long cove with kids what are
you hoping to achieve
uh with this campaign uh well
well it's both a campaign group and a
support group um
so i joined forces with uh sami
mcfarland who is the founder
and we joined forces in october because
um you know we were part of different
support groups and campaign groups for
the adult
community uh and and realized that there
was there was just a lack of anything
for children
um and the children narrative was just
being left out completely
of all discussions so we came together
really to to provide a group
for parents because it's a really
difficult place to be
um quite often the parents are ill
themselves and to have children who are
ill and
that that illness to be being denied or
for the parents sometimes to feel like
they're being um
gaslighted or so it was really just to
allow people to come in
and find other people and and then from
that we started to say well okay
we need to start getting this message
out that we need people to know
because we are not going to see a change
in the support for our children unless
we actually
uh raise awareness of this so that's
that was enough
so francis uh you and your children
would you say you have fully recovered
now
um it's difficult to say i'm much better
um the last really i mean i i was really
ill until about
september so from march to september
and then i uh and then i took some time
off work i
rested completely now i
have a relapse um probably twice a month
uh of a few days and i have to go you
know take myself back to bed and i have
to rest
um but i'm quite aware of of you know
when um right and but my children
uh no they're not better and they they
have relapses whenever they
do anything that exerts them um they
went back to school
uh the last couple of weeks to see how
they'd get on
and they've been ill since they since
they finished right
well francis simpson uh thank you so
much uh for sharing your experience with
us all the best to you and your kids of
course
thanks for being on the program thank
you
well last year no one dared to hope that
we'd have a vaccine
so soon and while most of us embrace
this fantastic achievement
we also wonder if there could be any
unwanted side effects
it's time for your questions now here's
our science correspondent derek williams
could a vaccine cause a positive pcr
result
just a quick reminder first that that
that pcr
stands for polymerase chain reaction
and and tests that employ the technology
are considered
the gold standard for for detecting
the viral genome in swab samples
now because some vaccines use
information from that genome
could they also trigger a positive
result
um this question comes up all the time
and and the answer is
is no believe me if it did then
you would have heard about it because
millions of vaccinated people
would have suddenly started testing
positive for covet 19
after getting shots there would there
would be no way to distinguish between
them
and and asymptomatic carriers it'd be
chaos
but but nothing even remotely like that
has happened
now if you get back a positive pcr
result it's almost certainly
because you've been infected even though
you might have coincidentally
received a vaccine a day or two
beforehand
don't forget that it takes your body
around
two weeks to build up a significant
immune response after you've received
the first dose of a vaccine
and in that time people do catch
covid19 quite a few i i get email from
them all the time
the science behind why vaccines can't
cause
a positive pcr result is fairly
complicated but basically
boils down to the fact that none of the
currently approved vaccines
use a full version of the real virus
to to kick-start an immune response
instead
they're based on short specific
stretches
from the sars cov2 genome that that
actually
degrade pretty quickly in cells they're
not detected
by pcr only replicating
viable viruses so if you test
positive it's time to talk to a medical
professional
the vaccine is not to blame
[Music]
and eric williams will be back to answer
more of your questions again tomorrow
before we go and this is not an april
fool's joke
if you are anywhere with a mask
requirement you will know the problem
every time you want to eat or take a sip
of your drink you have to remove it
potentially putting yourself and others
at risk
well here's a possible solution the nose
only mask
it allows you to take a bite while
maintaining at least some level of
protection but zero
dignity it's been invented by
researchers in mexico where street food
is particularly popular although it's
better than nothing the who points out
that a mask that covers the nose
mouth and chin is certainly best
and that's all for this edition of our
kobe 19 special from me and the team
as always thanks for watching stay safe
you